the guard is always like are you on the
show i'm like yes and he's like
extra's over there i'm like
sir i'm number one on the show
number one and i would literally i would
always leave a call sheet on the side
you see this asian name that's me
lost
i kept getting cast in an american
project but that would follow through
like i would i would think
oh finally i'm going to get to act you
know i kind of missed acting in english
it's slightly different you know my
first audition was lost it was with jj
and he was with the whole gang up ryan
burke and everybody and because jj got
delayed
i was like one of the first or the third
person going in
and i i was just like oh my i got so
annoyed because
my mom was coming in i had to pick her
up and it's like
my mom is more important than audition
right i didn't really know i was like oh
who's this jj guy so late and i waited
and you know i kind of like walked in
kind of like a little annoyed and but i
kind of used it and this is what's so
cool about jj abrams he was like you're
not right for this role
and i was like okay thank you very much
it was like wait sit down let me get
back to you
i was like okay
and i was like i rushed to the airport
and that's when i got the call they
literally called like an hour later and
said we love her we want to write her a
role we don't know exactly what but can
we hold her so and then literally like
within couple hours they created the
character
son
and they asked if i would feel
comfortable speaking korean on the show
and i was like
sure
but i'm gonna eventually speak in
english right i need to talk to you
i knew like if if we were gonna fail it
was gonna be like crash like it was
going to be bad failure but if we were
going to succeed i knew we would be
pretty big when we first started
press for lost one of the abc publicists
came to daniel day kim and i she came up
to us and she said do you know that you
guys are the first two asian americans
to be cast as serious regulars on them
on a network show
and i said no really i don't know if she
went through all the history or the all
the lists but it's so easy to believe
your wife had an affair
what
dying with me was so tragic it's like
so beautiful at the same time that was
sort of like what our character
represented
we were sort of like the heart of lost
you know
[Music]
shitty
i got cast in a movie called shiri and
when i read it
i was like
and i didn't even audition that's the
crazy part this was never a plan
i never thought i could
you know i would act in korean
and actually live in korea you know what
i mean that was never
in the realm of my reality back then i
was born here in seoul korea
my whole family immigrated when i was 10
years old
and
you know
obviously i didn't speak a word of
english
and so once i got there i would just sit
there like a mute child so i went
through that type of phase and uh my
teacher i was like why don't you try
like drama club after school so i was
like uh okay that's when i started
getting the the confidence and sort of
like learning to use my voice all over
again sort of started out with you know
junior high school and then i auditioned
for the high school of performing arts
it's you know when i went and it's still
fiorello h laguardia
but you know the famed school so i got
like two three books of monologues and i
picked two out
and i didn't know what i was doing
so i and i went and
surprisingly i got in
and that's when i really learned what
acting is and all that and my god and
i've been hooked ever since i went to
boston university and major in acting
and
i got cast in a korean miniseries
from new york we started shooting in new
york and then they
i had to come to korea to finish it off
and then i went back that aired i
started getting calls from korea i was
just like i don't
i don't think i could do
acting here the director wanted someone
new their shots of me just the eyes or
like the back of my head if they if he
cast a famous actress in that role
people would you know know but my
identity
the character's identity had to be
sealed so obviously he was looking for a
fresh face and
i just had a meeting and i got cast and
then i found out who my
partner was gonna be and who was gonna
be in the film and i was like
what the actors who are in the film are
like we're like the top of the top i
tried everything to get the character
right
and because i didn't i wasn't used to
the film medium i didn't know how much i
needed to portray
how much it was going to come across
you know i was so
you know i had no idea what i was doing
and when i when i play the the role the
sick woman
who
the lead takes the identity of you know
we did the fake tooth the wig and the
whole like skin you know because she's a
sick woman
we did all that but like still i wasn't
sure i couldn't trust all that now i'm
like oh i trust you guys and
i don't you know i just do but but like
i didn't eat for
about a week
mistresses
mistresses i mean i obviously i wanted
to play a role that was very different
from lost son even though you know i
love i love i love playing sun on lost
i wanted to do something sexy something
fun
something light and mistresses came
along and it was my
i mean it was just
you know obviously you know it's always
about four women navigating you know
love and after sex in the city you can't
have three or five it's gotta be four
women gotta we've missed you what have
you been doing these past few months and
who have you been doing you look way too
good to be wasting all this action on
mental cases
honestly i wish i had something more
interesting to tell you guys but i've
just been working non-stop
alissa was sort of like the last person
to
like i met the other two actresses we
hung out and we kept saying where who's
going to be who's going to play her
who's going to play sofie but
but like her deal took a very long time
so anyway but i mean it was just like
wow i used to watch you on television
she was like the biggest child star i
mean i used to be like oh i love her
she's so pretty
but you know like just now she's like
one of my cool friends my life is on the
line
you can't talk to me about it that's
fine i get it
but i am done playing nice with this
woman make sure you tell her that i am
not going down without a fight and
whatever i pull in a new location you
know because we drive ourselves not like
here but the guard is always like are
you on the show i'm like yes and he's
like
extras over there i'm like
sir i'm number one on the show and i
would literally i would always leave a
call sheet on the side and i would be
like you see this asian name that's me
it's great isn't it that i get to tell
this i mean and he he means no harm he
just doesn't know and he's not used to
it because he's never seen it before but
i'm going to show him now listen you see
this asian name that's me i'm asian and
i'm the i'm number one on a network show
okay it wasn't just me you know there's
that you know of course daniel day kim
sandra oh john cho
now steve young come on i mean like and
they happen to be korean americans oh
it's my father
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i always came back to korea to to work
every break i had every hiatus
i had a project and obviously
once you know you sign a contract for
seven years on a network show
you have to get permission to do
anything even though it's outside of
united states so it never felt like i
ever stopped working here in korea
i just
went away for nine months to do
something else in a different country
and then i came back i was already very
good friends with the director he said
it's male driven
you know movie
and he was literally like i'm so sorry
but
you're gonna have to do this can you
please do it
like
i'm gonna make sure i'm gonna take care
of your character and i read it i was
like i don't care if it's based on um a
male character i mean it's literally
translated into oh to my father it's not
owed to my mother
and i was like it's totally fine and he
was like no we're gonna add you in in
these like the quangju sequence where
he's looking for his sister that whole
sequence he wanted to add my character
into it i was like no
i think it's better with the
you know with his best friend going
there and doing this journey just with
him i was like plus i have to work who's
going to open the store right i mean
like you know just in the world of um
so he was like really and i was like
it's totally okay and after seeing a
film he was just like you were so right
about that my heist korea
i saw the first two seasons of the
original money heist
and i saw it when i was back in l.a huge
fan of the show so i was like is this
right i mean why touch it it's like so
amazing already
the script really convinced me just the
whole premise of you know we're on the
verge of unification with north korea
and south korea and so forth and just
but each location like in the task force
i'm butting hence with north korean you
know negotiator as well
so there is an extra layer ujin is not
only battling the professor you know the
robbers in the bank
and trying to save the hostages i'm
battling with another layer with the
whole tension between south korean cops
and north korean cops and then budding
heads the politicians giving us pressure
i thought this type of layer
and um just combining
the new elements
in the script it really worked can i
tell you i used to dream like
after like a very stressful day feeling
lonely out of place
feeling like i'm starting from scratch
when i was shooting lost
i just put my head down like about to go
to sleep and i used to be like
i wish here is korea
like i wish it would switch the career
that i built
would just kind of like switch and i
would get the same thing
in america that i would you know do you
know what i mean just switching places
kind of i'm not saying that's what's
happening now but the just the the idea
of
being able to shoot everything that's
korea in korean with korean directors
producers korean system especially with
korean actors
and then it gets shown in like
other countries
like who would have thought i'm so lucky
to be part of it
in the middle of it
if this is actually happening in my
lifetime who would have thought you know
i'm thrilled